wow let's talk a little bit about this
this morning an op-ed in the new york
times warning parents to pay attention
as education takes center stage in the
republican midterm agenda they're going
to capitalize on the op-ed arguing for
30 years polls have shown that americans
trusted democrats over republicans to
strengthen our schools within the past
year however republicans have closed the
gap voters who feel looked down on by
elites are now finding common cause and
an alliance that could not only cost
democrats the midterm elections but also
fundamentally
realign u.s politics brian fox weekend
co-host will kane joins us right now hey
a will a lot of people under playing
education that was a that was for the
off year elections do you think it's
going to be a midterm election big deal
i think it's going to be a big deal for
elections here into the foreseeable
future brian not just midterms but for
presidential elections as well
acknowledging the limits that the
federal government has over our local
education although they wield quite a
bit of influence and persuasion look at
what's going on look at school board
meetings talk to anybody in your local
community when i go out here in dallas
texas and talk to friends
education is one of the
main things they want to discuss now i
have school-aged children i have middle
school and elementary-aged children but
everybody is concerned about whether or
not their children are being taught what
is in their correct estimation
uh a racist ideology whether or not
they're having racism forced down their
throat whether or not gender ideology
and sexual ideology is being forced down
the throat of kindergartners through
third graders as is being fought against
in the state of florida look there are
certain things in politics i think you
should never ever mess with and at the
top that list has to be people's
children don't mess with my kids if you
do you don't just lose me for an
election you lose me for all elections
sure
it's interesting you should mention that
that's the one topic that so many
parents want to talk about my kids are
out of school but i talked to my
next-door neighbor for a half an hour
yesterday about our middle school in our
town you know will in the mid-term what
we saw last year uh in virginia was
essentially uh the democrats were the
party of the union but it seemed like
the republicans were the party of the
parent and that's why the new york times
says hey pay attention to this
yeah advising their own readers to not
take education for granted despite
decades of support on the education
front and by the way we shouldn't
overlook the fact that that same party
has embraced an ideology that punished
our children unnecessarily
unscientifically when it came to covid i
have children steve that have had their
sports cancelled for the better part of
two years they're in new york city
they've been forced to mask until very
recently and by the way they're the last
holdouts on who had to mask every other
element of society has been allowed to
move on but not the children so the
children have been punished and there's
one more element to this look
there was an idea that i think actually
spanned both democratic and republican
party and that was that the way to
succeed in this country was through
education and the education's job was to
give you the tools right through
calculus or through history to navigate
our society to become uh more productive
more wealthy
more grounded member of this society but
that's changed now calculus has become
less important or infused with for
example race ideology so the democratic
party has moved education from the tools
of merit to the tools of social activism
they're not trying to create you know
citizenry who is ready to go out into
society and and create that next great
company they're trying to create
children who are ready to take to the
streets and change the fundamental
nature of what they see as a very flawed
country and i don't think parents want
that parents want children who have the
tools to succeed not the tools to change
elections yeah well we saw in virginia
when glenn youngen won that america
really is waking up and like you said
the mama bears and the papa bears are
saying don't mess with my baby bear
because that's the most important thing
in my life or one of the most important
things
um what do you expect for the midterms
i think not
solely but
primarily or at least heavily because of
the issue we're discussing i think the
republicans are absolutely going to have
historic victories during the midterms i
mean it's going to be coveted policy
it's going to be war it's going to be
immigration and yes it's going to be
education as well
find me a issue right now where
republicans won't be winning over
democrats i imagine a lot of five-hour
fox and friends weekends uh for uh will
kane uh five-hour shows because i know
you love that all right that was one
weekend i think that was a one i was two
two of three two of the last job well
done all right well thank you very much
ten hours rest your voice hi everyone
i'm brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now